alright hey everybody we have quite a
night ahead of us planned we are
starting on YouTube and then of course I
think four reasons people are very much
acquainted with at this point the actual
debate analysis and live debate is going
to be happening on Twitch and there's
definitely a nonzero chance that the
entire thing gets completely shut down
not because it's on PBS but because
apparently CNN is a broadcast partner
and they are going to be repeating it or
you know involved in some way so anyway
we'll do what we can it's unclear how
long we will be on but I will try to be
with you through the full duration of
the debate I will be here until the top
of the hour we'll be going over the
polling entering the debate we will take
a look at some of Donald John Trump
tweets in advance of the debate and of
course related to his impeachment we do
have an impeached president and it'll be
a curious thing to see how much that
topic comes up today of course the one
person in history I think that has ever
voted present on impeachment tulsi
gabbard did not qualify for this debate
so it would be an interesting
conversation maybe to involve her
but alas she did not qualify um let's
see here if you have questions or
comments before we start send them via
super chat and then they will pop up on
the screen as you can see in the lower
left right now two new members Martin
Fogle and grace and ease have signed up
there and I will take questions there
people asking where will we be doing the
full debate once again the full debate
coverage will be on twitch twitch.tv
slash David Pakman if you want to get a
jump on things I'll be switching over
there just before the start of the
debate follow me over there follow me
over there but we will be here for now
let's start by looking at polling and
then I will get to super chats it is
risky when I do the thing where the
super chats are automatically on-screen
because sometimes anti-semitic screens
will appear and then all of a sudden I
have to fumble to get them off but I
think most of the folks that are
watching right now are very very good
people as Donald Trump would say so
don't think that that's going to be a
problem okay polling going in on average
right now the situation is that Joe
Biden is still in the lead averaging
twenty seven point eight percent but a
pretty significant reversal as you can
see here the blue line is Bernie and
there was this pretty long period from
mid September all the way through around
November 21st during which Bernie
Sanders had fallen to third place Bernie
Sanders is now in second place outside
of the margin for error so tonight is
actually a really big night for Bernie
now of course as we've talked before
Michael Bloomberg has been rising in the
polls of polling an average of five
percent and recently polling as high as
seven percent as you can see here but
Bloomberg based on the current rules
cannot even conceivably make the debates
because there are donor requirements and
Michael Bloomberg is not accepting
individual donors so what will happen
with that there are questions as to
whether the DNC would consider changing
its rules between now and the seventh
debate which I think is scheduled for
January I believe January 14 and of
course if you are already a candidate
and then the DNC says hey you know what
we're gonna change the rules and it just
so happens to let in Michael Bloomberg I
would be furious and I'm assuming that
they will at the same time having a
candidate who is now effectively in
fifth place doing better than all of
these other candidates Klobuchar yang
Booker Gabbard steyr Castro Bennett
Delaney Williamson who have been in this
thing for a long time it's weird because
just by polling we should have his voice
in there but the rules are the rules you
live by the rules you die by the rules
and that is exactly what is going on
folks asking in the chat if the website
member target will carry over to twitch
course I'm not a savage anybody who
signs up during the YouTube portion of
the stream will be switching over to
twitch at the top of the hour merely
just for kicks right why would we be
doing that anybody who signs up during
this up section those memberships will
carry over and count towards the goal
and on that on that note Chris Coons
stat Chris Khun stat is today's first
website member of the evening that gets
us to one of 25 you can join Chris use
the coupon code this is 20 at join
pakman.com by the way I'll give you a
secret there's a code last 20 19 which
it's such an obscene discount that I'm
not even going to tell you how big of a
discount it is but you can take
advantage of that if you want ok let's
go and see what's on people's minds over
in super chat because the super chats
are coming in robber clobber says with a
$5 super chat I love Medicare for all
but I think we need to slow walk it
because Americans buy into the fear and
will revolt sadly we saw it with the
Affordable Care Act I don't agree with
you in that we need to slow walk it what
I do think is going to happen and I know
part of my audience hates me for this it
seems extremely unlikely that we would
go from what we have now to Medicare for
all I believe that there's going to be
some kind of a phase in if that is the
eventual end point there is going to be
some kind of a phase in it could be a
longer one a shorter one people can
debate it but I think that there will be
a phase in folks who are here on YouTube
asking about twitch at the top of the
hour we will switch over to twitch so
jump over the you don't want to watch
this stuff on corporate media watch it
with me over on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman I see all sorts of
people are following me over on Twitch
and there are people already chatting
over on Twitch so we we will get over
there at the top of the hour but for now
we're here answering questions awesome
gaming says via super chat could Bernie
Sanders get into first place of course
he could of course he could the question
is can he do it on the basis of a good
performance tonight the further into
this stuff that we get as the candidates
are known as the positions are known the
less that any one debate can really move
the needle unless you really mess up and
that's what we've been seeing if you
look here at this polling data and you
see you know Biden down and then up and
then down the downs correspond with a
lot of the debates Biden hurts himself
during the debates and it's easier at
this point
the game to do damage than it is to help
yourself unfortunately because a lot of
the positions are known justin haddock
says via super chat I love haddock
haddock is just a fish and chips
gotta love it David you're beautiful and
I love you and sends a rose all right
thanks Justin I appreciate that and this
weird thing is going on where there is
another super chat but I can't see it
until another super like I can't scroll
down any further
it's really weird actually let's see if
I can find it elsewhere
that's soup there's a super chat off the
screen Oh
downfall parodies says why does the
right wing say that America is a
republic not a democracy they use that
whenever anybody points out that there
are some anti-democratic things going on
but it's it's a ridiculous argument
we've actually had a constitutional law
professor on to talk about it and
they've they've explained how these are
these are really semantic games that
Republicans are playing and that they
don't really mean very much about we are
supposed to have representative
democracy we have a constitutional
republic and enshrined in that is the
assumption of a representative democracy
Republicans use it whenever they want to
justify of anti-democratic ideas or
actions let's see here day says will CBS
allow live streaming the debate I don't
believe the debate is on CBS I believe
it's on PBS I don't know if they will
allow it but we are going to be
switching over to twitch at the top of
the hour at the top of the hour the
stream will move over to twitch.tv slash
David Pakman my phone is just exploding
because people are just very very fired
up about tonight's debate so at the top
of the hour we will switch over to
twitch and I will let you know when that
is when that's happening for now we are
taking questions via super chat that's
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window
we are also welcoming new members and
the numbers will carry over let me
welcome Shane Collier and Ken Florence
Shane Collier and Ken Florence that gets
us to three of 25 website members when
we switch over to twitch
I have the slickest new graphics for the
members where we were at with you and
you're gonna love it
it's just it's amazing what's going on
over there oh and also Ken module II Ken
module II has also signed up so that
actually gets us to four out of 25
website members let's see um Val from
Agawam known to many of us as Val McLin
she says David I still think we need
children of the lie the band yeah so a
lot of a lot of people probably don't
know what that is this is the idea and
so let me back up I play drums the drums
is my strongest instrument I've looked
at drums very strongly for many years
and then I play a little bit of piano
but not good enough that I'd play piano
in a band I had the idea of having a
band called the children of the lie
which is the insult that Jesse Lee
Peterson this crazy conservative uses to
refer to people like me and others on
the left and we would do a song under
the band name children of the lie and it
would be me David Pakman on drums
Anthony Mellon Fantan Oh on bass
Steven Destiny's bonel ii on keys and
sam cedar singing okay now i pitched it
to them and Sam said you know I really
don't sing well and I said well you
could do like a singing parody you're an
actor and you know you are you are who
you are you're a voice actor of course
and Steven destiny bonel ii and Anthony
Mellon fanta know they both sort of said
yes
but I think they think I was kidding so
I went back into them a second time and
I was like guys I want to do that band
thing I think it'd be really funny and
we could have a music video you know for
like a four box where each of us is
laying down our our track and stuff and
I think they think I'm kidding so like
it's it's um it's embarrassing for me to
continue it continue mentioning it it's
like the friend who keeps saying yeah
but didn't we want to go bowling tonight
they know we want to go bowling tonight
yeah yeah bowling so if you guys want
the children of the live band to happen
please contact these people and tell
them that we should do it because I'm
ready I'm totally ready I've got
acoustic drums that are miked and ready
to go I've got electronic drums if they
prefer I can film the things
that's the idea children of the lie band
I should just turn my phone down because
this it's just it's gonna be a crazy
night I can already tell I apologize
that's very very rude let me welcome who
do I want to welcome Larry Wiig fall and
Owen can vary both are new members at
join pakman.com that gets us to 6 of 25
don't worry if you sign up here the 6
will transfer over and actually that six
is very quickly become 7 because Zachary
Monroe has also signed up thanks a curry
I appreciate that let's go to other
super chats Booker King says what is
your yang favorability on a scale 1 to
10 personally I really like the guy he's
the candidate I know the best I've
interviewed Elizabeth Warren a couple
times I haven't seen her or talked to
her for years
Bernie won't return our calls
Andrew yang has done the show two or
three times although not for a long time
and he should really should do it again
but my favorability on a personal level
I would say Andrew yang is a 9 he's
never said anything that I found a
personally offensive he hasn't made any
anti-semitic comment towards me so I
start with people at a 9 until they give
me a reason to like them less than that
awesome gaming says I forgot to ask who
should drop out of the race ok I mean
let's just look Williamson I thought did
drop out but she should go
Delanie I thought was out but he should
go Bennett I thought was out and he
should go who leon castro probably can't
really justify staying at this time Tom
Steyer never should have gotten into it
and since he's buying his way through it
he'll probably stay but I think you
should go tulsi gabbard
should absolutely go and then if you're
at 2 or higher you can think about
staying in now Booker I think that the
only the top the so the top from the top
8 the to the top two rows here -
Bloomberg are the people in tonight's
debate I think right Cory Booker made
tonight's debate do we know that for a
fact I don't have the list in front of
him they can justify staying in but
quite frankly if they don't do anything
in the Iowa caucuses it's going to be
time to go that's only like
six weeks away now or something like
that at the okay welcoming new people
here we are doing the pre debate show
here okay at the top of the hour 8 p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific we're switching
over to twitch twitch TV slash David
Pakman so follow me over there I will
let you know when we switch over and new
member signups will will transfer over
as well
dan samoflange says how many do you
think will drop out after tonight I
don't know if anyone's dropping after
tonight to be perfectly frank will see
Steve B wants me to pledge support to
Andrew yang via super chat but we don't
we don't play games via super chat very
very childish so I hope that was worth
$2 for you
a twz RR p RZ says only look fat look
fat do I look fat can you oh my that's
not good if I turn sideways are we oh my
that's uh that's that's a terrible thing
if that's true L legend says here's my
$5 contributing to the band children of
the Y thank you
Canadian citizen number 273 says why did
Buddha judge dip in support recently
yeah let's look at that Buddha judge in
purple here from about 11 3 down to 83 I
think that it's not that he dropped in
support I think that basically this
little pop was a glitch because you can
really kind of trace a straight line
that would cut across here I just think
that the the the blip was a glitch I
actually don't know that it ever really
reflected his actual support devil drum
says David withhold impeachment from the
Senate yes or no I think it's a good
strategy I think it's actually I have a
video about this coming out in the next
couple of hours I think it's a it's a
very very good strategy and I outline
why ml says Tulsi gabbard's constant
attacks on the DNC love for conservative
media and not voting for impeachment
makes me make me think she's a Democrat
in name only not only do I not disagree
or agree with you I'm I'm not only
voting present on your assessment I
don't even care that's the reality dali
lama's he says did you watch our email
bar on MSNBC today fire no I haven't
watched
just I don't watch any anything I don't
watch anything Matthew long says how can
you still be undecided for the primary I
know it's crazy isn't it it really is
Baron Steuben says should cory booker's
request for debate restrictions to
loosen to allow for more minority
candidates be taken seriously listen all
along the problem has been not enough
I'm sorry not strict enough requirements
so the idea of loosening them now to me
does not seem particularly logical no a
downfall parodies oh wait hold on Daniel
Krieger says I hope someone brings up
the Afghan papers I brought it up on
yesterday's show and it's a big scandal
and I hope it does come up downfall
parodies asks Wendell John Delaney drop
out he's delusional if he thinks he has
a chance he doesn't think he has a
chance it's just what does he think he
can get from staying in w.a says no you
don't look fat you're the healthiest
looking progressive out there spoken
like Donald Trump's doctor thank you I
appreciate it let me welcome a couple of
new members just one I guess Steve B
Steve B is today's 8th new member of the
evening new members will transfer over
to twitch we are here for the pre-show
as many of you know we've had issues
issues as someone I know used to call
them live-streaming debates on YouTube
we once had an issue live-streaming a
debate on Twitch as well but we're going
to try streaming over on Twitch so
closer to the top of the hour I will
switch over there let's take a look at
Donald Trump's tweet feed I'm just
curious if he's going crazy as they say
but he is okay so let's start with him
let's start with an hour ago that's when
he seems to have gotten back on his
phone I think yes okay so Donald Trump
starting with quoting Greg Gutfeld
never a good start Jesse Watters this is
the best year any president has ever got
had plus we get an impeachment Wow
why does my laptop keep restart oh here
we go okay Trump going on to say the
great USMC a trade deal has been sitting
on
see Pelosi's desk for eight months she
doesn't even know what it says and today
after passing by a wide margin in the
house Pelosi tried to take credit for it
labour will vote for Trump trade deal is
great for USA Trump going on to say so
after the Democrats gave me no capital D
capital P due process in the house no
lawyers no witnesses no nothing of
course they were offered all those
things and they refused them they now
want to tell the Senate how to run their
trial actually they have zero proof of
anything they will never even show up
they want out I want an immediate trial
this is why I think Nancy Pelosi
negotiating the terms of the trial is so
good because Trump is so easily trigger
about understand that until there's a
trial Trump is a sitting impeached
president around the world when they
talk about Trump he's a sitting
impeached president he doesn't like this
he's easily triggering I think that it
is absolutely delightful and then Donald
Trump also tweeting the House Democrats
were unable to get even a single vote
from Republicans on their impeachment
hoax
the Republicans have never been so
United the Dems case is so bad that they
don't even want to go to trial well they
want to go to trial when it's going to
be a fair trial Donny boy we've got an
end-of-the-year Trump compilation by the
way called Donald Trump President of the
United States I previewed it today
producer Pat did a tremendous job
editing it together and I think you guys
are going to like it we're gonna publish
it during our upcoming vacation let's
see first in last kappa says hey david
have you seen or talked about this whole
christian publication turning against
Trump I find it funny I haven't I
haven't heard anything about it
Bernie's bro says yang you bi forces you
off of Kant funded by regressive VAT
I believe that he has changed those
parameters my friend I know that you're
identifying as a Bernie bro but I think
some of those elements have been changed
John McClain McLean says is Jimmy door
more Sant ammonius each day I have not
seen Jimmy doors show really period I
mean years ago I watched when I would
comment on a clip here or there I
couldn't tell you the
first thing about what's happening on
that show I haven't seen it James Justus
who's president now that Trump is fired
well that's that's a reason a lot of
people are concerned which is do we
really want Mike Pence a lot of people
don't just a few minutes we're going to
twitch at the top of the hour if you
have the twitch app great if you don't
download it now or you can just go to
twitch.tv slash David Pakman my handle
on twitch is just David Pakman and we
will go over there in just a few minutes
I see a lot of folks following me over
on twitch I think we're gonna have a
very good stream on twitch this evening
and for copyright purposes we will be
going over there Jake Bingham says it
looks like RealClearPolitics polling
average included more polls than usual
in their candidate average looks like it
was done to benefit Amy Klobuchar
positions on Chloe Amy Klobuchar
position on stage what are your thoughts
I don't I mean so the the I but I
thought that the positions on stage were
not based on anything Real Clear
Politics does it was based on just the
polls that are out and that are
considered so I don't know that I'm on
board with you Jake in terms of how
that's determined Troy Baker says is
geoengineering necessary for a
government change plan I don't know that
it's necessary but we've certainly
talked to some smart people who say that
it would be advantageous advantageous to
say the least a lot of argument in the
chat you know it is a little bit
depressing when I see people in the chat
with this stuff where they say Bernie's
the only guy that can beat Trump nobody
else can or yang is the only guy that
can beat Trump nobody else can or
debarred is the only person who can beat
Trump nobody else can I I don't think
that any of those assertions are based
in fact let me say welcome to Alex
McNall ski thanks Alex for signing up on
my website ronald felts and Tamika
DuBose that gets us to 11 website
members 11 website members this evening
the target is 25 and certainly mark my
words folks those memberships will carry
over
to the twitch stream that will be
starting in just a few more minutes John
McClane says he dad tulsi was the only
right vote man I don't know what John is
talking about Oh is Jimmy door more
sanctimonious each day he said Tulsi was
the only right vote on impeachment I
mean who cares I don't know I don't
it's I don't I'm not worried about it
other folks you know everybody has the
wrong lane they have their own audience
they can do whatever is good for them
James Justice says President Michael
pencil just doesn't sound right yeah I
mean it's what's worse Trump or Mike
Pence neither is either is good squirrel
squirrel iosys who's super chat is not
yet up on the screen because for
whatever reason I need the next super
chat to push it up says worst-case
scenario Bernie gets the nomination
losses in landslide to trump we can't
forget this is totally possible listen
any of the Democratic candidates could
lose in a landslide to trump it's very
unpredictable small things that we can't
even conceive of until October 20th can
make it so that the turnout differences
swing the election I think it is very
plausible that Donald Trump loses the
popular vote maybe by even more than he
lost it in 2016 but ends up with an
electoral college victory I think it's
also possible that he gets absolutely
destroyed I mean just brutally brutally
destroyed uh while Walker --'tis says
are you on Lee chess or chest comm I'm
on both I'm David Pakman on both Lee
chess and chest comm and my ratings
range depends on the the time format but
anywhere from like 950 on really fast
chess up to 1350 on I think maybe on 10
minute or something like that let's see
other super chats wolf pack says we all
know you that you go Trump winning we
all know you that you go Trump winning I
don't know
sorry I don't know what on earth you're
talking about I'm very very very
confused by that
welcome to everybody who's just joining
me we are just minutes from the start of
the debate so we are now switching over
to twitch okay forget about watching on
corporate media we're gonna end this
stream in two minutes I will be back at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman on browser
or just David Pakman on the twitch app
okay I'll see everybody shortly on the